(Bob) Let's start this bad boy I'm ready
(Mark) I am so ready
(Mark) Uh, I didn't get any items
(Mark) DO WE STILL HAVE THE MILLIONS OF GOLD
(Bob) Oh I didn't look we probably still have a fuckjillion
(Bob) of gold
(Mark) I don't wanna even use it
(Mark, obviously lying) I'm not a CHEATER
(Mark) I would never cheat
(Mark) EVER
(Bob) Dick Lickly is going to have the revolver ok?
(Mark) Dick Lickly... *weird chuckle* That always just makes me laugh
(Mark) huhhahahaHAhuh
(Mark, realizing his mistakes) ha
(Bob) *WHEEZES* THANKS BUD
(Bob) Thanks for your sincere laugh
(Bob imitating Mark) ba hahahaHAhaha
(Mark) it's just, this just tickles me so goodly
(Bob) Dick Lickly? ha! a preposterous
(Mark) So let's see ok I've got
(Mark) I've got my
(Bob) Do we want to trade roles at all?
(Mark) No no, I like doing calls out
(Bob) Woooah
(Mark) When I do call out
(Bob) Mark
(Mark) What
(Bob) I like how long your periscope is
(Bob) Hang on, wait. Hang on check this out, watch, watch this
(Mark) Yeah I'm watching
(Bob) *grunts*
(Mark) wOOOOw
(Mark) Wow man, Dick Lickly has the longest periscope I've ever seen
(Mark, in awe) Woooow
(Mark) I'm gonna, I'm'unna, ok so what I'm gonna do is, my call out system is
(Mark) Enemies are gonna be a number, and that's a number on the clock
(Mark) Right?
(Mark) LOCATIONS is gonna be left, right, middle
(Mark) and that's generally the path that you should go
(Bob) Ok, left, right middle
(Mark) So, so if
(Mark) an enemy pops up I'll be like 5 o'clock, path middle, path left, path right
(Mark) or go right or (dying) LEFT
(Mark) Left right middle and I'll always call where the open path to go is
(Mark) and you'll totally be able to rely on me
(Mark) I'll be there by your side
(Mark) Do we want one gun or two gun
(Bob) Uuuhhh, one's probably adequate for the beginning, we might need to up that
(Mark) Ok. Middle.
(Mark) Path middle.
(Mark) Path middle drifting left. (Bob) Alright
(Bob) Oh, is that an enemy? What is that? That's a purple fish, okay we're good.
(Bob) Never mind just a happy fish. (Mark) HAHA
(Bob) There's an update so there's gonna be new shit we haven't seen before. (Mark) Oh really? Oh, okay.
(Mark) Far left, far right. Go left.
(Mark) Right is a boss fight. (Bob) Alright (Mark) Left normal cave.
(Bob) So yeah there's gonna be, there's gonna be some new stuff probably. We may have to fight a new boss if we get far enough.
(Mark) Oh hell yeah.
(Mark) You know I love bosses. (Bob) I think we're ready.
(Mark) HEYA CAVE. IT'S A CAVE.
(Mark) WE GOT A CAVE. (Bob) IT'S A CA-HA-AVE
(Mark) IT'S A CAVE.
(Bob) Is this a hermit cave or is this a - no.
(Bob) Alright stay behind me boys!
(Mark) Alright.
(Mark) You got it Dick Lickly.
(Bob) AH! AH! Wait why would the guy with the -
(Bob) I'm trying to lick them harder! (Mark) Why would the guy with the gun not be behind?
(Mark) Ah! It's on my face.
(Mark) Help! Shoot me! Shoot me in the face!
(Bob) Oh god, I'm shooting you! I'm shooting you in the face.
(Mark) *laughing* Thank you. (Bob) Okay. Don't worry bud.
(Wade) I'm here.
(Mark) Eh! (Wade) I'm here to help!
(Bob) Mark could probably use a couple whacks.
(Mark) Yeah man, if you could whack me.
(Wade) Let me whack ya.
(Mark) Yeah please whack me. Thank you. (Wade) There you go.
(Mark) You're not - you're not whacking me. *laughing*
(Wade) Consider yourself whacked.
(Mark) Thanks. I do.
(Mark) Alright. Mmmm, wait there might be a path up there, (Bob) Oh there's perils down here!
(Bob) Yo boy, I found some friends! There's crabs dropping down
(Bob) There's Carol, Carol the something's down here. (Mark) Ok, nothing up here.
(Mark and Wade) Carol? (Bob) Carol the Nimble! x2
(Mark) Carol? (Wade) OOH! Carol the Nimble has a got uh, uh, uh
(Mark) Carol? Carol!
(Bob) C- Ow!
(Bob) *smaller ow*
(Bob) Can you touch me daddy Wade?
(Wade) Yeah!
(Mark) Alright.... (Bob) Thank you.
(Mark) We got a backpack up here-
(Mark)Maybe Wade- We got two backpacks
(Bob) Uhh, you guys can have em
(Wade) I'll take one
(Bob) Uhh, I'm useful being a gun daddy
(Mark) Uhh, ok you wanna exclusively be
(Mark) gun daddy that's fine...
(Bob) Yeah, I could be our violence man
(Wade) *in the background* WHEEEE!!!
(Bob) I shoot the guns on the boat,
(Bob) I shoot the guns in- Oh
*Mark laughs*
(Bob) You came from that way...
(Mark) *quietly* Hey (Bob) *nervously* Hi
(Bob) Are we, uh, is there more?
(Mark) This is it.
(Wade) *strange WOOO noise*
(Wade) There's a thing there!!
(Wade) I'm just gonna... pretend like I wasn't letting it...
(Mark) Thanks for the wax, daddy!
(Bob) Can you give me a wham, a whambo?
(Mark) Sure
(Bob) Whambo Bambo?
(Wade) You guys are telep- My screen's still broken, so you guys are just...
(Mark) How is it still broken????
(Bob) Maybe when we die you should just reinstall this game....
(Mark) *dramatic gasp*
(Mark) I know why, I know why!
(Mark) Wade!  I know why!
(Mark) 'Cause you're a weirdo and you play on a 4K monitor!
(Bob) Oh, you have a 4K monitor??
(Wade) Yeah! Is that a problem?
(Bob) Oh, that's probably a scaling issue at that, yeah
(Mark) Yeah!
(Mark) Why do you play on a 4K monitor? That's just...
(Bob) 1440 is where it's at, my man!
(Wade) I- I think 4K's nice...
(Mark) Yeah, well...
(Bob) I don't think Wade's on the helm...
(All) *laughing)
(Wade) I was like, wait, the ship's moving